...bruitages suspence
Ah !
*rires* *c'est gênant*
Ah... c'était pas prévu que ma jambe esquive le rouleau
Alors, il vous manque le Squeezie de 2013, hein ?
Les amis, aujourd'hui nous allons faire une vidéo, comme on les faisait en 2013 !
Et ceux qui étaient là, comprendront pourquoi je dis ça.
À l'époque dans le gaming, il y avait deux écoles : celle de Call Of Duty et celle des jeux indépendants.
Et souvent les jeux indépendants, c'était souvent des jeux d'horreurs car c'était un peu les plus simple à faire...
et c'était surtout ce qui faisait le plus kiffer les gens.
Aujourd'hui, on va jouer à un jeu d'horreur !
Vraiment. Très beau.
...
Comme à l'époque, on va faire semblant que le jeu est génial même si il ne l'est pas.
*rires*
On est sur "3:00 AM at The Krusty Krab" !
Pour ceux qui regardaient Bob L'Éponge, vous allez kiffer.
Bref! Oh non, l'interface ne fait tellement pas rêver...
On est bel et bien en 2013 !
Quand tu peux choisir la qualité des graphismes sur le menu du jeu : c'est très grave.
OK, c'est parti ! On joue Mr. Krabs ! C'est tout ce que je sais.
*soupir de Mr. Krabs*
[Mr. Krabs] Money!
Il y a une cinématique, c'est trop bien !
Oh putain, c'est la pince de Mr. Krabs !
Vous allez voir, on va faire genre que tout est ouf, comme en 2013, vraiment.
Ok donc là, il a juste...
...
Ah putain ! C'est en QWERTY le jeu... comme en 2013.
Alors, choses à faire :
Rassembler l'argent qu'il y a dans la caisse et dans tout le bureau
Rassembler les derniers euh krabby patties (paté de crabe)
Checker les poubelles dans la salle de bain au cas où il reste quelques euros
Fermer le restaurans et partir. O.K. !
ho non ! un grand méchant nous rend visite
Quand les lumières clignotent, euh va te cacher
Mer** mer** mer** je me cache où je me cache où gros
"closing/barricading the office door is the only way to escape him"
O.K donc le seul moyen de lui échapper c'est de barricader le bureau.
là je suis en zone safe et je fais quoi ensuite
Il faut que je rassemble l'argent qu'il y a dans la caisse
OK, alors on va aller dans la caisse. C'est ça la caisse ?
Oui
...
Ohh c'est long !
Allez rassemble plus vite M.Crabe, fait très très vite.
Rassemble tes euros très vite. Fait ça aussi vite que "David Lafarge"
Et on sera "archi" bien, STP, allez !
Nooooon
(???)
...On a eu chaud,
Ahh pardon, c'est moi qui vous ai fait peur, je suis désolé
Je suis le screamer en faite dans cette vidéo, c'est incroyable
Putain mais il rode avec sa spatule ce petit enculé
Tu n'auras pas un centime de mon restaurant
Qu'est-ce que l'on a de ce coté là?
Ahh, je crois qu'il faut rassembler les burgers. Oui c'est ça !
On les "Pack totalement"
C'est super long ...
Franchement, en même temps j'avoue il a des pinces à la place des mains, mec
Imagine toi faire tes lacets avec des pinces, et pas des mains, c'est chaud quand même.
Non, mais en vrai.
Oh ! OHHH !
WOOOOOH !
Je n'ai pas eu peur en vrai
comme en 2013
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire après ?
ahhh ! bah il faut qu'on prenne l'argent qu'il y a là pu**** j'avais pas capté
ça j'ai l'habitude, honnêtement après chaque OP c'est ce que je fais :
je ramasse comme ça l'argent et...*rires*
aaah il faut checker dans la salle de bain
aaah à mon avis il faut passer par là
aaah regardez en toute logique
et il faut faire quoi ?
*paniqué* il faut checker quoi j'ai pas compris !?
aaah il doit y avoir...aaah ok il faut checker la poubelle !
aller fouille mec c'est pas si long, vraiment dans une poubelle je t'assure quand il y a 2 serviettes :
tu trouves facilement l'euro si il y en a un
tous les objectifs sont complétés, trouve la clef dans le "basement" et barre-toi !
c'est quoi déjà le "basement" ?
OOOHHHH !
OOOOOOOHHHHH !
il m'attaque à la petite cuillère le fils d'eup
non..!
OOHHH !
AAHHH !
alors, on a dit qu'on faisait comme en 2013, il faut sur-réagir c'est important
c'est l'élément crucial d'une vidéo de 2013 pu**** !
BONN !
attend il faut tout recommencer !? oh nann...
et on rassemble les burger ! *en chantant*
et on ramasse l'argent de la caisse *en chantant toujours*
et on observe la grande qualité graphique de ce jeeeeuuu ! *oui, il chante toujours...*
et on récupère les euros dans la poubelleee *chanson terminée*
et on est enfin au même point que tout à l'heure !
alors, il faut qu'on fasse quoi ? faut qu'on trouve...euuuhh...
il a dit "trouve dans le basement..."
c'est quoi ?...pu**** oh nan je vais vraiment faire ça !
oh regardez ! c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
oh regardez ce qui est en train de se passer !
OH ! (on dirait un orgasme MDR)
je suis humilié !
excusez-moi, il fallait mettre des effets de 2013 un peu dans cette vidéo
alors il est ou le sous-sol !?
attend mais il y a une trappe là !
quelque chose me dit que ça mène au sous-sol
la clef est quelque-part dans ce sous-sol...tu dois la trouver...
oh bah tiens dis dont ! c'est vrai que ça rajoute un peu de minutes de gameplay
et je me cache où du coup quand ça clignote ?
...
non mais là je suis à l'abri, entre deux caisses mec...
*se fait tuer dans le jeu*
OHHH !
WOUAWOUUUWW !
ok on y retourne
Je savais pas que Krusty Krab, avait un sous-sol aussi grand mec
en vrai son loyer doit être hyper élever
c'est pour ça que c'est une grosse pince
en plus d'être un crabe qui possède 2 grosses pince du coup
*hurlement*
...
C'est pas facile hein...
En vrai je fait le mec, mais c'est en train de m'énervé à fond
ça m'énerve vraiment de ne pas trouvé la clé et de me perdre dans ce sous-sol
si mal fait, si bien fait pardon
*musique*
nan mais c'est génial
Mais je viens d'apparaitre... Non mais là c'est...
Les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo comme on faisait en 2013, ...
j'espère que ça vous a plu. En vrai, j'vais vous dire la vérité, j'ai passé un trop bon moment.
C'était vraiment marrant de rejouer à des petits jeux indépendants comme on faisait à l'époque comme ça.
Faudrait peut-être qu'on fasse ça plus souvent finalement...
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu et si vous étiez là en 2013.
Allez trève de bavardages, j'vous fait des gros bisous et à très vite sur YouTube.